in the past hour the british transport
police have confirmed that three people
including the train driver have died and
a further six
have been taken to hospital the train
derailed after storms and mudslides
took place in the area
we can now go straight over to the scene
where the british transport police
are giving an update officers remain on
scene this afternoon alongside the
ambulance service
fire brigade and colleagues from police
scotland and the major
major engine operation has been underway
very sadly despite the best efforts of
paramedics we can confirm
that three people have been pronounced
dead at the scene
where formal identification is yet to
take place the driver of the train
is very sadly believed to have died his
family have been informed
and are being supported by specially
trained families and officers
officers are continuing to work to
inform the families of other two people
who sadly died
six people have been taken to hospital
to be treated for injuries which
thankfully are not
believed to be serious this is a tragic
incident and first and foremost our
thoughts are the families and friends of
those
who have very sadly died this morning i
would like to reassure the public that
this was not a busy service
and from cctv inquiries and witness
statements we believe all passengers
have been accounted for
however once the area has been made safe
then our full and thorough search will
be conducted
which is likely to take some time
however once the aid has been made safe
then a full
and further full and thorough search
will be conducted anyway concerned about
friends or family can contact your
casualty bureau
on oh one four one seven seven five five
one
two two i know many people will
understand they have questions
and the investigation will be directed
by the clean office and procreate fiscal
service
we'll also be working closely with them
alongside the rail accident
investigation branch and the office of
road and rail
to establish the full circumstances of
how this stream
train came to derail thank you
do we know how many people so there we
are that's the confirmation from the
british transport police that uh three
people
are dead after uh the train derailed
near stonehaven and what pictures
they are and uh one can only
reached the conclusion that uh this was
a mercifully
um uh not many people were on that
train 12 people were on the train six
staff and six
passengers but one can only imagine
given what
you can see there what would have uh
the death toll it could have been but
nevertheless
three people have died in this accident
and uh which is thought to have occurred
after storms and mudslides hit
the area and you can see one derailed
and overturned down an embankment
that carriage there and other carriages
also uh derailing and overturning
uh correspondent gerard tubb is at the
scene
and he uh joins me now so these are
uh well extraordinary scenes at this
accident gerald just bring us up to date
with uh
the latest that you know they are truly
shocking aren't they
um to see that the state that that train
is in with one completely
uh detached carriage um partially burned
fire truck going past still emergency
vehicles uh coming in the house as you
heard from british transport police that
search operation still going on at least
one of the carriages uh partially burned
um we saw the smoke
rising from um where the train is hidden
from
uh the public viewpoint here as far as
you can get on the road before the
emergency services have taken over for
this major incident with all those
vehicles they have uh parked
up there um as you say that only three
people died tragic of course
though that is uh if that train had been
busier looking at those pictures
quite clearly this would have been even
worse
it's interesting that the british
transport police have given
so few details and no questions allowed
at that very brief news conference which
was really only
an officer reading out the written
statement that was issued
half an hour or so ago the crucial
question
is if this was the 638 trainers we
understand
leaving aberdeen going to glasgow why
was it three hours later that the
emergency services
the the emergency call was made about
this derailment it's only 20 miles
as the crow flies it's a twisty line
going through
a hilly area it moves inland away from
the coast to get through
the hillsides here with steep hills on
each side we know there had been very
heavy rain
torrential thunderstorms in parts of
scotland last night which went on
and on huge amounts of water
there were floods in many areas and
we've seen pictures
of standing water on railway lines you
could understand that there may well
have been
uh landslips we don't know what caused
it but
in this area that is what you might
expect after
very heavy rain with such steep sides at
the side of a railway line
but why did that train if it was the 638
take three hours to get here
and how could this derailment have
happened if the conditions
were bad where three of those carriages
by the look of it
have been completely derailed it looks
like one's upside down one is completely
detached from the train
and some considerable distance away from
the train
and another one across at least one
other carriage
truly astonishing pictures
very dramatic and a horrendous job for
the emergency services we had
the air ambulance coming in we had the
coast guard helicopter coming in this
morning scores of ambulances
the ambulances have been moving out many
of them going back to
providing cover elsewhere as they
realized that they had those numbers
locked down
um the the six people taken to hospital
without
serious injury if those figures are
correct that we understand six
passengers and six staff
then three people weren't injured at all
six people have been
injured but not seriously and tragically
three died
but it is due to the coronavirus due to
the pandemic that there were so
few people on that train because you
have to socially distance you have to
wear a mask there's no catering
and it wasn't many weeks ago that the
government was telling people it was
their civic duty not to travel on public
transport of course so
rail services are not being used uh
heavily but
british transport police explaining that
they still have a job to do to make sure
once everything's safe and they can be
sure it is safe to
carefully search those carriages some of
which have been burnt out as you can see
that they need to make sure that there
really were only
six passengers on that train that is not
a pleasant job
they will have to go through very
carefully those carriages
but they should be able to tell us soon
you